hello my name is Ross Kagan I believe
i'm online now this is my first time
doing an online talk so it's as if I'm
giving a talk to myself which is fine my
name is Ross Hagen I am a professor and
associate dean and also i am director of
the center for personalized cancer
therapeutics at the Icahn School of
Medicine at Mount Sinai and actually as
declarations and I'm hoping my slide
will show perhaps that you're right so
I'm also this is my declaration I am
also co-founder and on the SI b & board
of directors of Metro's nothing i'm
going to talk about is nothing i'm going
to talk about is directly relate to that
company but i do want to disclose it
okay i'm also editor-in-chief of disease
models and mechanisms and i just want to
mention that because i hope everybody
here is considering sending their next
paper there okay and this is the outline
to my talk so i am a drosophila
biologist what i'm going to talk about
today is how we use flies to develop new
types of drugs and new approaches to
cancer therapeutics my laboratory also
works in diabetes and we develop we both
explore and develop therapeutics for
diabetes but i'm not going to talk about
that today if one topic and stay with it
so i'm going to talk about really two
approaches that we take one is i'm going
to talk about how we use flies and
chemistry to develop complex drugs and
i'll explain what that means mainly poly
pharmacology and then i'm going to turn
i'm going to switch and i'm going to
talk about how we use drosophila in ways
that you really can't use other animals
to develop complex cancer models and
i'll give an example of why that matters
why complexity matters
and finally I'll finish my talk by
describing a center which we just opened
the doors on I am the director of it it
is the Center for personalized cancer
therapeutics where we use basic research
tools including drosophila as I'll
explain to more precisely model the
asked the complexity of the patients
tumors and then using high-throughput
drug screening develop whole animal
based therapeutics for those patients
and part a lot of my talk will be
explaining why that matters let's see to
push this okay so i have many slides
that I often start with when I give
talks for this one I thought I would put
out this I see it's actually a merger of
two slides it's okay and what this is
showing is the cost for that the cost by
Pharma from 1952 today to develop a
successful drug and that's cost per drug
I'm sorry I said sorry drugs per billion
dollars it went from a hundred drugs per
billion dollars to well less than 10
drugs per billion dollars in 2010 okay
and this is inflation adjusted now this
looks very impressive where this curve
is going down but actually it's more
impressive because if you look carefully
on the Left you'll see it's actually a
logarithmic scale in fact we are getting
worse in a logarithmic way now what's
the problem so in a reason I bring this
up is because I'm really answering in
part the question why drosophila and
part of my answer is that we have many
great models and a lot of very smart
people working on it but it's obviously
difficult problem cancer and disease in
general and in fact we've been we've not
been very good at developing successful
drugs the hit rate is quite low and
sometimes I'll show the success rate of
clinical trials and for cancer it is
commonly in the single digits for
success rate but it's ridiculous so
what's the issue and as I see here he
slides emerged
so I'm relatively new to the cancer
field and so coming into it I've been
thinking about what are some of the
things that have been issues and what
are some of the assumptions that we've
made in developing therapeutics one is
there has always been a push by myself
included to try to simplify the disease
that is can we find commonalities
between patients initially it was trying
to find that one driver that's important
maybe it was the driver you study when
you're a postdoc maybe it's a driver
that you were taken to buy a screen and
then you focus on that one gene and you
sort of beat that to death maybe even
the whole pathway and the idea is then
if you drug that is that should knock
out the disease a problem with that of
course is that it's complex disease and
I'll make that a finer point when I show
you some of the data that we have and i
will show you examples where actually
when you account for the complexity
drugs that work in simple disease models
don't work in complex disease models and
i'm actually going to really push that
issue of embracing complexity even
potentially to the point we embrace as
much complexity as we can so in other
words we're trying to push the opposite
direction how much complexity can we
pour into our models also there's been
an assumption not unreasonable and not
always untrue actually sometimes it's
true that the driver of the disease is
also the best therapeutic target and our
examples of this EGF receptor is an
important driver for certain cancers and
it has been a terrific therapeutic
target but in fact in most cases when
you I think in most cases genes that are
so fundamental to the biology of the
cell that when you just change them a
bit they can cause dramatic problems
like cancer diabetes and so on these are
so fundamental to a biology the cell
that when you drug the patient when you
drug those down in a patient that can
cause toxicity and in fact it's been
shown in a number of studies recent
studies that
therapeutics our overall more toxic than
more basic chemotherapy and so again a
lot of the drugs that are successful in
the marketplace if you ask what do they
do they don't hit the central pathways
that we all know in love what they
really do is they sort of nibble around
the edges of the network sort of push
that network back into some semblance of
normalcy and then we can get along with
that push but in some cases the disease
cannot on now also sort of riffing off
this a little bit there's the issue of
single versus multi targeted drugs this
has been a debate in the field that has
heated up actually when I got started it
was no heat it was pretty much everybody
was for single targeting drugs I'm a big
fan of multi targeting drugs for reasons
I'll explain and finally cell based
screening versus whole animal screening
I would say that they are simply
different some of the differences and
advantages the whole animal screening
are obvious some of the disadvantages
are obvious you can't screen as many
it's less precise but when in all the
whole animal drug screening that my lab
has done we've really gotten to think
about some of the advantages of it that
we hadn't really considered when we
started this and some of the key
advantages are that when we look at
where are these drugs actually acting
most cases the drug head hits multiple
targets some of those targets are
actually on the tumor on you know the
sugar uptake aspects of the cell but
many of the activities of the motor
successful prove drugs are actually
elsewhere in the body so they act on the
liver the act on the muscle which then
somehow acts back on the tumor and in
fact I suspect that in many cases when
you have two drugs that are supposed to
hit the same target one is successful in
the clinic's one is not it may simply be
could be because of the so-called off
target effects are in fact important but
important elsewhere in the body was the
person you take a drug you're drugging
with the whole body and the that means
that you'll identify a class of drugs
that you will not identify in a cell or
in vitro based screening
and I would argue that that is a
potentially successful class but the
onus is on us to show that so let me
move forward so a few words about
discipline here we go a few words about
discipline for those of you who haven't
thought about flies in a while maybe
since high school or college and you
probably remember there are white eyes
and red eyes and if you cross them
together somehow couple generations
later if you do the punnett square you
can figure out how many white eyes you'd
expect all that stuff so flies have come
a long way from this to summarize which
you can do in a fly which has flat out
for most powerful tools of any
multicellular organism model organism we
currently have you can turn any gene or
genes on or off in any cell not cell
type not conscious time but any cell at
any stage you wish jiri okay and almost
always it's with off-the-shelf reagents
that you just order in from various
toxins and that for a cancer is very
powerful so we can begin to think about
making a 3 4 5 hip model or even beyond
as I'll explain we've really been
pushing the technology it really changes
which you can do so other things about
flies they most of the basic structures
that we have our conservative flies they
have conserved epithelium so my lab
really focuses on solid tumors in fact
they're really the only simple model
organism that you can do I throughput
screening in because they have conserved
epithelia simpler organisms really don't
they have most of the organs we have the
app charts they have livers they have
kidneys and so on in my lab studies then
as do many others the majority not all
that the majority of genes that drive
disease and us are conserved in flies
and in fact much of what we know about
the major signaling pathways I shouldn't
say much but a lot of what we know but
the major signaling pathways actually
comes from flies and that's why these
pathways have crazy names like notch
hedgehog went and so on these are
actually descriptions of phenotypes you
see when you knock them out and fly
and so as i mentioned i would consider
flies to be really sit in a cancer sweet
spot animals that are more complex like
zebra fish and Mike's they're wonderful
but they're not very good for
high-throughput screening simpler
organisms like C elegans for example
don't really have epithelia the way we
do or not exactly the way we do and so
you don't see a lot of solid tumor work
in them flies really sort of hit that
sweet spot they have a nine day life
cycle they're very cheap you grow lots
of them in a single block file so
they're very easy to work with there are
plenty of disadvantages and flies to the
major disadvantages in the details so we
try to think of flies as putting us into
new areas new chemical areas or
therapeutic areas new ways of thinking
about disease but we don't obsess with
with perfecting a drug in flies or
obsess over working at the tiniest
details of the mechanism implies then we
actually once we have the question and
clarified and we'll put in the right
place then we move to mammals and ask is
this true in a mammal in most but not
all cases it is okay and they do have
other differences they do have an immune
system they don't really have an
adaptive immune system in the same way
we do they don't have unibody ones for
example and that's important to think
about some aspects of information so
there are disadvantages as well and so
the best so what we try to do is that we
try to leverage those things that are
strengths and flies by choosing
carefully what diseases that we study
okay so I'm going to start with a model
that we developed some years ago this is
actually my entry point into disease in
the labs entry point and we were
actually a development lab like most
Asafa labs neural development and after
a conversation with a colleague of mine
paul good fellow a human geneticist who
is studying a disease called multiple
endocrine neoplasia type 2 and the major
problem in these men2 patients is a
thyroid cancer called medullary thyroid
carcinoma
some of you may be familiar with it some
not it's a relatively rare it accounts
for a few percent of thyroid cancers
however it is one of the more serious
ones along with anaplastic thyroid
carcinoma it is one of the very few
types that will actually metastasize and
can eventually be fatal the other
interesting thing about MTC's is that
the majority of them are driven by an
activating mutation in the ret receptor
tyrosine kinase and i have here on the
screen a high-resolution
crystallographic structure of rat it's a
transmembrane receptor it binds ligands
like gdnf it has a cofactor that it
complexes with upon binding it dimerizes
and activates down street signaling
pathways like grass Sark jun kinase and
so on many of the pathways that we all
know and love in the signal transduction
field it's a classic rtk but these
patients have activating mutations in
them some are born with it a quarter
than actually the majority it rushes
spontaneously and these mutations
spontaneously activate the pathway so
it's on all the time and although ret is
broadly expressed in your body it really
its major defect as i said is in the
thyroid in the power follicular or c
cells in the base of the thyroid and the
result is overgrowth proliferation
eventual metastasis and so on so how do
you model this in a fly well flies don't
have a thyroid I just told you they have
any organs but they don't have flat
photography although to be fair if they
have a very skinny neck so we may have
missed it but I don't think so because
they don't make calcitonin the other
things that C cells make so we targeted
to the eye in part because much what my
life study as part of the nervous system
and in part because flies can move
without their eyes so I'm going to I'm
going to talk a fair bit about these
rough eyes and so on
and so I'm going to get you used to it
so here in the middle panel of my cursor
is showing up everywhere but here in the
middle panel we have a wild type i and
you can see that the eye is nice and
smooth okay on the right side I we put
oncogenic Rhett either human or in this
case fly rep they vote for it equally
well in a fly by putting a single point
mutation in it the intracellular domain
and I hope you can see that the result
is a really bad looking like and if you
look closely you'll see there's a little
bowl just coming out of this I when
these are actually tumor-like growths in
it what you can't see if we cut cut that
open and looking underneath you'll see
cells leaving their classic metastasis
like behavior you see switches in cell
fate but you'll also see compensatory
apoptosis a lot of the things that you
see in real tumors in essence etc we see
in this tumor and in fact my lab is
really taking this apart and we've laid
out I think most not all the major
pathways that are triggered by aquagenic
we had to drive this tumor we use
classical genetics generally walk
through here we found 140 genes that
drive this disease ok I'll these can
drive mysteries now so we know quite a
bit about it but what we did was
probably more interesting is shown in
this slide now I did try to load a movie
here but unfortunately it didn't load
but if the movie on the right was
working what you see was a very slick
looking presentation where essentially
what we do is we grow flies in a 96-well
plate format so it's a little demeaning
to the Flies but it works we have
robotics that move food and drug into a
deep 96-well plate the robotics mix it
and my lab has four different chemical
libraries that emphasize druggable space
we then put we have a modified facts
order from Union biometrika at spits ten
embryos into each well okay so you have
960 embryos in in this 96-well plate we
put an oxygen permeable lid on top the
Flies hatch out they eat the food they
eat the drug and then we do basically a
phase three clinical trial
right there in the dish okay and we have
actually sweet nap we generally set up
the model to either have a very rough I
or even set it up so the tumors are so
aggressive they kill the animal and then
we just screen in most cases we look for
rescue from the Falla tea and we just
screen for drugs that unkilled apply and
it's very easy score you just look at
the plate there's anything moving in
there that's your job okay it's
wonderful it works well at my lab is
very good at this so we've really
pioneered this as a whole animal drug
stream so will this work well in the
early days we screened smaller libraries
including libraries that contained what
was in retrospect approved drugs at
least it was now food so one of the hits
in fact the major hit that we got from
our initial screens was again in on the
left you see a normal eye in the middle
you see an eye on oncogenic red express
just in the eye and you see the tomb is
coming out of it and on the right you
see oncogenic ret targeted to the eye
but now the fly has been eating orally
in the food in its well has been eating
a dragon called ZD six 474 and I hope
you can see that in the presence of the
drug it completely blocks the effects of
the opportunity that I it's not quite
normal but it's basically a normal eye
and we really didn't have another drug
that could make that I look so good
without basically killing the animal dis
drug could make bring the I all the way
back to normal at a 30-fold lower dose
and was required to kill the fly so in
other words if you were a fly and if
what was in your food was is what's in
you and I would say the therapeutic
index is 30 which is a pretty amazing
therapeutic index for anti-cancer drug
so i have to say i got very excited
about this this was when i was at
watching medical school I went running
around medical school saying you can
cure these patients you just given this
drug so apparently you can't actually
take drugs from flies and given the
people which was very first of many
disappointments in this but to cut to
the chase at this time there's also some
really important work that was done by
massimo Santoro who's a biochemist and
in cancer biologist over in Naples
he showed that this same drug ZD six 474
was an effective ret inhibitor and was
not originally designed as a redhead oh
this was made by astrazeneca to attack a
completely different receptor called by
Jeff receptor but that it could
successfully repress rat and other
targets as well and they were able to
show in a scene graph model that it was
effective so based on all of this data
samwell's took this drug into the
clinics with astrazeneca so
astrazeneca's on our first paper i'm
showing basically these images i took
this drug into the clinics and to cut to
the chase this was a crude so this is a
CT scan of an early patient but actually
I'm not gonna get into this had more to
talk about so it was approved as the
first chemotherapy for measure every
[ __ ] so honestly that worked better
than I expected so I switched my lab out
of development full on into disease
moved to New York to to the icon school
of medicine at mount sinai and we've
really focused completely on disease
mainly cancer and diabetes so what have
we learned from this drug what is it
doing is it just inhibiting ret while
our genetics actually told us and i
think i'll show you a bit of data on
that that having a clean ret inhibitor
is actually not the way to go to
successfully knock this tumor out
because flies probably like us you know
we need with it in other parts of our
body to to vote for normal homeostasis
so what you want to do is dial ret down
but you don't want to dial it out and
that means you're going to need to hit
other targets as well and in fact we now
know based on in vitro kinase data that
ZD six 474 in which many of you know has
been detonated it is basically the
world's worst kinase inhibitor it hits a
lot of things a lot of cases and he hits
them poorly well what's magic about it
is it hits them in just the right ratio
that the fly can take that hit as it
turns out we can take that name but the
tumor has difficulty selecting around
that to get around that and in fact
patients who are on this those that do
respond and about sixty percent plus
respond to this they commonly
respond for several years before showing
resistance and we think that's in part
because it hits so many different
targets that the tumor has difficulty
finding Road around all of those
different hits and so that really taught
us a lot about what we feel we need in a
drug lower specificity hit multiple
targets and but do it in a whole animal
system because it would be almost
impossible to predict out which things
you would need to hit it without at
least getting a constant whole animal
view of what's toxic however just
building low specificity kinase
inhibitors that applies is very
difficult because the chemist will
complain fairly that if they don't know
what's the important activities they
don't know what parts of the molecule
they can manipulate to optimize it for
people and so they can't work okay so we
so the question is could we come up with
a method to do what we call rational
poly pharmacology that is build a drug
that hits multiple targets but in a
rational and whole animal way when we
monitor everything that's important and
that takes us here and this was a
collaboration with a colleague of mine
kayvon show taught a really fantastic
medicinal chemist over at UCSF really
one of the very best medicinal chemists
especially specializing kinase
inhibitors and this is work done with
his postdoc Arvind are we now stole and
is now a professor at Mount Sinai and
really my my postdoc Derek to das was
spectacular who is I'm now just deciding
where he's going to move into his first
p I John I'm and this was I think these
guys did really an impressive job in the
thick and what they did is as follows so
no more rough eyes no more tumors in the
eyes they now set up a system where they
express the oncogene oncogenic right in
several parts of a flaw in a way that
basically killed the fly ok so the fly
is now riddled with tumors and dots and
as I mentioned when we do drug screening
we actually like death because then we
can rescue from death and that's
the Flies are a little up and down about
desk but if it works for us so they set
up the system with express rat in
several parts of the fly and they
calibrated it you can see this here in
this bar so that half of the Flies
survive to pupation okay and none of
them survived to adult right so its
larvae it starts embryo larva pupa adult
they make it all the way to pupa and die
because the tumors kick in around that
time and then make it to adult now we we
didn't have a clean red inhibitor so k
Vaughn's lab actually I generated one
which is the cleanest I'm aware of that
the highest codes we can give back red
inhibitor called dl 06 you can see that
it doesn't do much to help the animals
before and any higher dose essentially
killed all the interns okay so coming up
with a clean retin Hitler did not seem
promising so we screened a library and
this library was special library reason
I actually went to cave on is his
specialty is building libraries of drugs
that target multiple targets in their
case for research purposes but the good
news is they built it from a library
that had drug that has druggable
properties so screen this library the ad
series so called from art and daughter
who built the livelihood and we got one
hit which I'll call a d1 and you can see
why we like 81 and that's here in the
middle I don't have a pointer but
whatever a d1 you can see that you have
a higher level of animal surviving be
patient and finally we're actually
getting adults out okay so we're very
excited we're getting my thirty percent
of dogs very great very good now um z
let's see I think this will work yes
something more should happen there we go
okay so you can tell that we've patented
this drug because i'm showing you the
structure so here's the structure of 81
on the left now what's interesting is we
looked at close analogs of 81 other
drugs that were almost identical but
with small changes for example 82
is identical to 81 but it's missing that
trifluoromethyl group that you see in
red on the upper left and that small
change causes 82 to become highly toxic
actually getting fewer animals that no
drug at all 83 is identical to 81 but
instead of a single methylene group
shown there in red in the middle between
those two rings it actually has two
bonds there and that's sufficient to
kill a lot of activities a little bit
activity but nothing impressive so um
what can we learn about these drugs from
these both the drugs at work and the
drugs that didn't work and can we build
a better 81 now what I didn't tell you
mercifully is that we had done this
large genetic screen actually did
mentions we had 140 genetic modifiers
things that drive led-based
tumorigenesis and the majority of them
fell into three basic pathways which I'm
going to summarize here rass signaling
which is dominant for proliferation
Sark's signaling which my lap spends a
lot of time looking at which drives
metastasis okay and pi3 kinase signaling
which has a number of things that sort
of pumps the whole system up okay so it
contributes to both of these pathways
and audience and also regulates
metabolism now the rate limiting enzymes
in these are raff and tour and sulk okay
and those happen to also be the three
druggable enzymes in that pathway right
these are kinase asst rap and torrent
site so let's look at it in human in
vitro kinase panel and ask what does ad
1 2 and 3 hit regarding these actually
for kindnesses of the include rat all
right you can see at the top here on the
Left plus means higher activity for the
drug you can see that ad 1 2 and 3 all
hit ret well but that doesn't correlate
with their activity in the animal as we
discussed now let's look at 81 it hits
Sark it hits be rapid and send Tory hits
all three pathways that our genetics say
it has to hit and that's why it works
now let's look at 82
82 hits art it hits mtor but it needs to
be rap alone now why would not hitting a
target make a drug toxic and this comes
to a concept that Kayla and I call anti
targets which are a drug targets you
actually want to get out of the drug
because they're causing problems they're
doing what we call unbalancing the
pharmacology okay and what we and
actually a number of other labs some of
them before us showed is that there's a
feedback loop between mtor and wrath
signal okay so if you think about it
mtor suppresses grass pathways for
example suppresses the effects of beer
app if you fail to inhibit b-raf and you
inhibit mtor you've removed the
inhibition of b-raf and you have read
signaling through here and now wrath
signaling Rises not just in the tumor
and actually 82 makes the tumor worse
but it rises throughout the animal we
were able to show in a number of ways
that 82 is toxic because it's causing
wrath signaling to rise so people to
think that all the way that you'd
realize yes lost that makes sense if you
inhibit end where you donate be wrap
that pathway the beer at pathways gonna
turn off now we know that's causing the
toxicity now how do we notice now we can
turn to classical fly genetics if we
take a d2 and remove one copy of the
downstream target of the RAF Burke so we
just dial it halfway down a little bit
you can see now all the toxicity of 82
goes away look at this now all the
animals make it to pupation and we even
start to get some adults now 82 starts
to look a lot more like 81 so if you
think about it that's a great concept a
great tool to use we could actually walk
through the fly kinome a protein by
protein high-protein and just ask in the
presence of a knockdown in this protein
does a draw get better or worse and stay
the same if we knock a target down in
the presence of the drug and the drug
works better we would say that the drug
needs to hit that harder if we knock a
target down and the draw
becomes toxic we would say we got to
keep that activity out of the drug okay
we can do that in a very controlled
lation away so for example is 82 as good
as it gets know if we remove a copy from
Earth from 81 you can see now that's a
drug we would love to have you can see
that 81 is not perfect if we further
balance the pharmacology so we have it
hit a better balance of a rap verses
things like and tour that we can make a
drug that really if you're a fly will
cause all of you to live to adulthood
and these flies look so fine we actually
have to double check by out crossing
them to make sure they still have the
cancer genes in them on the other hand I
told you that hitting mtor is bad it's
an anti target suppose we did that in
the presence of 81 if we do that what we
find is that a d1 now starts to look
like a t2 it becomes toxic okay so if
you didn't follow that it doesn't matter
it's okay the basic point here is we can
stepwise map out what are the activities
of any of any drug what are the
activities that need to be improved on
by hitting harder and what are the
activities that are causing problems and
by using this simple procedure we can
rebalance drugs they have to say we're
doing this now for other drugs besides
us which I'll get to in a minute so we
went back to cave on and arvin we said
please make a derivative 81 but it has
to have the following properties it has
to it has to continue repress threat it
has to continue to repress our it has to
hit b-raf but not too hard and it has to
leave mtor alone but you still have to
hit that pathway remember enters
infinite or kinase pathway you know pi3
kinase is important you have to hit that
pathway and so how do you do that well
we propose to hit the next kinase down
s6 kinase okay which I'm showing here on
the bottom left enter actually acts
activated s 6 minus which is below the
feedback me alright so what do we have
they actually did this if it's a
modeling they should if you add an extra
charge groups out of the fennel group we
can block the binding to end tour but
still retain some of the other binding
we can get essex activity and cell
and they sent us back to drugs which
I'll call 81b and 81 city and I hope you
can see here on the right anyone be an
81 seat now these are the drugs we would
really like to have these are the drugs
that at least if you're a fly will knock
your tumor out without killing you
remember the left side the black bars
are basically toxicity the right bar
it's basically efficacy and it's all
good now let's look at its in vitro
kinase profiles on the left here ok
let's look at 81 be it hits ret it hits
Sark but not too hard it hits be wrapped
but not too hard it leads the mtor alone
which is good and it hits s6 kinase to
knock that pathway out that's the magic
ok so are these drugs just graded
treating flies the answer of course is
no we have done an enormous amount of
work in mammals let me just show you
some of the data if we take human cell
lines and grow them in a dish not a fan
but when it tells us something vendetta
nib we show that it actually works quite
well to knock out an MZ crc one cumin
men2 V cell line which has an a
activating mutation in the extra Soto
domain over at sorry in the
intracellular Manor bread and you can
see van detinan does a fine job in the
micromolar range of knocking this out
however 8080 which is actually 88-81 be
an 80 57 which is 81 81 and we have to
change those labels they work about five
hundred fold better okay in a dish and
be fair bleach works even better so that
tells us something but not everything so
we put those cells or a similar cell
line the TT cell line into a mouse to do
xenograft studies we didn't cheat we
actually grew the cells up in the mouse
for 46 days to get a full-blown tumor of
at least 100 milliliters and then we
asked Ken the drugs reverse the Chairman
this of course is more relevant to
patients you don't go into your doctor's
office and say i think i might be
getting a tumor please give me something
to prevent it you actually won the
doctors obviously and say i have a tumor
can you reverse it so in that case
bandetta nib
fares very poorly in shrinking the tumor
but a DAT does a great job of knocking
it down okay if you look at the
individual tumors many of them actually
goes down and sometimes I show the
waterfall fought about and now the last
question is what about toxicity well
then debt nib has a well-known tux that
you can see here in the brown bar the
lower one and this is not labeled
somehow but the round bar lower one is
vendetta nib and it has a toxicity if
you just feed it to mice and weigh them
but ad 80 or 81 @ Amy one beam which is
shown in the blue bars is
indistinguishable from controls from
DMSO to try to the black bars basically
we can't find toxicity for these drugs
at very high doses and we think that's
because we've really balanced the
pharmacology okay so the concept here
which I'm very excited about which is
shown here is that we start with a fly
that we've built a tumor model or any
disease model in that we care about we
run it through a robotics to find an
initial hit and then we walk through the
genome either the kine own or if we have
to the entire genome we identify targets
and anti targets that when tweaked in
the drug would make the drug better in a
whole animal setting they come back to
medicinal chemists and basically give
them a list of how to change it if
they're good at their craft and some
like keyvan and arvin am very good at
the craft they can use modeling design
and then eventually build these better
drugs and then we come back to the home
models whole animal systems and testing
and what my lab is doing now is we're
actually using this approach to take
known drugs such as Sarathy nips in it
nib and so on we've actually already
mapped out what their problems are we
know these drugs have well known
toxicities you've already mapped out
what this problems are and we're now
working on creating we call super trap
nets in with sunitinib which are
rebalanced chemical analogs that are we
hope better in a whole animal at a whole
person setting okay
and we're doing this for other diseases
as well but you know what I need to know
about me ok I am I am going to share
this okay so I'm getting Lee time's
running a little on but I'm gonna I
think I'd go to do this quickly and then
I do want to show you one other thing
which is complex models actually know
what I'm not gonna show this to skip
over this and if I have chance at the
end I'll talk about it but I can
summarize this this is a concept I very
much like it summarized here so what
dare to das in my lab is now doing is
taking another what I think is really
very unique approach and he is screening
drugs and flies like always but what
he's beginning to focus on is not the
tumor but actually focusing on the
normal tissue so what do I mean by this
and I'll actually back up one here you
don't need to read this in detail but
just give you an idea he gives to fly
the drug like meets the drug and then he
pulls the normal tissue out as low as a
tumor tissue and he monitors actually 16
different readouts which with the full
colors you can see here okay he monitors
16 different readouts earth signaling
rass signaling ecad and so on win
singling we used mainly by running
westerns and using antibodies and he
basically when he adds a first drug says
oh okay it suppresses certain targets
but then other ones in response come up
okay and in the normal tissue you don't
want things too far down you want them
too far up that's called toxicity these
pathways so the way he rebalances it is
he looks at what goes up and down and he
gives the second drug to push the things
up down okay so now i have two drugs one
pushing here when pushing here but it's
like black them all you push these two
down another pathway pops up you give a
third drug you push that down and so on
and by the time you get to three or four
drugs if you're good at it which heat
which there too is you can get to the
point where you create a cocktail of
drugs that are extremely non-toxic far
less toxic than any of the single drug
given it the same dose but they are
highly effective against the tumor
because two is do not like having three
and four anti-cancer drugs knocking
to let me show you an example here here
is a fly's expressing a rat this again
is rescuing them from lethality saravia
rescues about fifteen percent of flies
to adulthood sarathy and plus bortezomib
moons that curve up to about twenty-five
to thirty percent so Ravin import
estimate plus an H deck inhibitor moves
that up to sixty percent and then if we
add a pi3 kinase inhibitor we can get to
over ninety percent viability in that
cocktail again at doses which are
otherwise can be quite toxic okay and
this I think is really exciting concept
which is can we create complex drugs or
drug cocktails where we are really
focusing on the normal tissue you keep
things non-toxic so the patient can have
a good quality of life with the idea
that the tumor whose network is in some
completely aberrant world is not going
to like that it's going to get pushed
into something it doesn't like and you
can knock the tumor out while
maintaining health of the patient so
this is something very excited about and
we're now beginning to move into mammals
to test these cocktails and mammals and
ask the question are they in fact less
toxic and animals are mainly looking at
mice and in pigs okay what I want to
really focus on instead because my time
is drawing short is the flip side of
what I've talked about so I talked a lot
about building complex drugs in a
stepwise fashion using flaws but at the
beginning i waxed on about the
importance of embracing complexity the
complexity that you see in the tube and
so we are taking steps to do this and
what I'm showing you now is work by
eridan bangee a fabulous postdoc in my
lab it's really taken I think an
interesting and unusual approach to
going after colorectal cancers so how do
you model colorectal cancer now this is
something we can model in a fly because
they do have a gut and actually
electrically speaking as well as
structurally it looks a lot like ours so
what airdam did is he went into the
human patient sequencing databases
and he asked what is the most common
double triple quadruple quintuple and so
on combination of oncogenes and tumor
suppressors that you see in individual
tumors not adding them all up but what's
the most common combinations that you
see together for example the most common
quadruple combination you'll see in a
human patient colorectal cancer patient
is wrasse p10 a PCP fifties way so he
took that combination using transgenes
and targeted that to the fly gut using
magic flight rates and using more magic
flight tricks turned it on only in the
adult so he's creating tumors in the
adult guide and just in one part of
about the so-called hind guy okay in the
case of grass he put in a trench in that
activates it because it's an oncogene in
case of p10 ABC and p53 he puts in a
transgene that so-called knocks them
down because they are tumor suppressors
furthermore not only and I should say
that he the reason he didn't make a
quintuple combination is simply because
there are no currently sequence patients
that share five hits together because
the statistics really fall off sharply
but as I explained we can build 10 hit
modest as we need them so not only did
he build a four-hit model he built all
the subset triples all the subset
doubles all the singles as I show here
so 15 different transgenic lines for
every quadrille and i should say he go
for different quadruples for the four
most common quadruples okay i'm just
showing you one example one most common
so many was able to ask the question
what do all these various things do in
the context of other cancer genes so for
example let me just show you so he so
that he looked at six different
phenotypes that he could quantitate he
looked at hyperproliferation and what
I'm showing you here is an image of the
entire fly hindgut so it's part of the
gut on the hindgut and you can see here
where the arrows are that there are
polyp like structures growing up out of
here that's because these cells have D
differentiate or proliferating like mad
and so we see hyperproliferation we see
multi layering they're undergoing
something on an epithelial to
mesenchymal transition and then they are
migrating off to distant sites which
I'll show you in a moment
they also have a block and senescence in
certain combinations but not others a
block enable ptosis in certain
combinations and not in others and we
could really see these emergent
properties that we all knew their
emergent properties but it's really
interesting to see them and some of
these emergent properties were very
surprising so here is another image a
close-up of a cross section of a fly cut
at the bottom that green tube is part of
the fly gut I should say it's labeled
with gfp which is white screen to be
clear this for hit fly has nine
transgenes in it okay that would be
really tough to build into a mouse so
the green is the gut the red is the
muscle around the gut that blue they can
just barely see that thin blue hose like
thing is called a trachea that carries
oxygen is like our our arterioles and
what you're seeing is a green cell that
is actually walked out of the gut pushed
through the muscle wall what you see is
disrupted as now quark screwed itself
around so there's a single salva even
though you see several parts of that
cell on the trachea corkscrewed itself
around the trachea so it's bounded
source of oxygen it's now I'm going to
walk off the distant sites into the
abdomen even into the head into the
wings legs and so on and in some cases
that's going to form secondary tumors
and kill the flock classic metastases
like secondary Jones when it hits those
second sites it's actually going to
induce trachea trachea genesis into it
much like you see in geo Genesis into
our tumors to build new sources of
oxygen and build up those tumors it's
really remarkable how similar it is to
what we see in people okay so now here's
the big question what's the difference
from a therapeutic standpoint between a
one-hit fly which is you know like the
one hit k grass mouse that on the field
commonly uses or a four-hit fly in this
case a raspy 50 3 p-10 APC for ABC fly
so airdam feds 16 drugs mostly
clinically relevant drugs most of them
actually been tried in colorectal cancer
trials all of which failed all of which
passed the mouse that failed in
and he gave them to the one hit fly and
as you can see here on the Left 13 of 16
of those drugs worked beautifully to not
the tumors out in flies okay he then fed
the 16 to the forehead fly and as you
could see on the right 0 16 of those
drugs work all right so this is why
these drugs are failing in the clinics
because we're not accounting for the
complexity now airdam had built all the
subset triples doubles and singles so he
could actually map out what combinations
were driving resistance in these flies
and so for example with be easy to 35
which is a peer through kinase inhibitor
when he would which is Ben Cortez nib
which is a proteasome inhibitor by
themselves the quadruple was resistant
to them but what he was able to show is
that pairwise the two that the two drugs
were able to knock the tumor out and in
fact they work by a very interesting
mechanism in which for tesna changes the
network signaling of the tumor in a way
that makes the tumor sensitive to be
easy to 35 and then bz bz 235 which is a
dual pi3 kinase inhibitor then just
knocks the tumor out it's what we call
induced oncogene addiction and it's
another concept we're excited about in
this combination we have an enormous
amount of mammalian data I think I have
some here in a number of different
models on how to show you one this is
not fly model this is actually a mouse
colorectal cancer allograft okay of a
triple mutation raspy 10 ABC when we
give it either drug alone if you follow
the colors they are ineffective but if
we combine be easy to 35 Forte fortezza
meb together and that's the green ones
you see all the green is shifted to the
right and interestingly and exactly the
way it was predicted to the Flies the
lower dose of autism it actually works
better and that's true and flies and
it's true in mammals and so the ones
that work best is actually quite low and
if you're interested I can talk about
why that is the mechanism by which these
drugs work is novel and really
interesting but I need to move on
so the punchline of this section is
complexity matters and if you don't
embrace and model that complexity you
will you'll the drugs have the risk of
combinations making a tumor resistant
okay and so this is it's basically my
last slide okay and it is a slide
discussing my Center because to me this
is sort of the culmination of a lot of
this work that we've been doing and I
should say I think I said that I'll say
it again but that Cortez may be easy to
35 combination is in setting its way or
a similar combination is hitting its way
towards clinical trials we've written a
protocol and are waiting for its
approval and I probably didn't mention
but the ad 80 and 81 were also picked up
by a biotech company and we're hoping
that they will also get into clinical
trials other than a year or so so so
flies are not perfect but they have
their use and so we are now pushing this
to sort of its natural next step which
is thinking about patient therapeutics
and so I began a center called Center
for personalized cancer therapeutics and
join with me the co-directors are
marshall marshall poznan who is a
clinician and scientist here who's also
head who heads clinical trials for head
and neck and head of clinical trials at
Mount Sinai and Eric shot a PhD and
professor here he's also chair of the
department of genetics and genomics and
he heads the institute for genomics and
multiscale biology and eric specialty is
he is a brilliant and Esquire magazine
agrees on this point he is a brilliant
modeler and one of the top genomics
people within the country and so this
has been a really a powerhouse group at
the top myself excluded and the idea
here which I'm showing in very simple
here is that is that pathologists come
and remove the tumor all of the tumors
removed from the patient pathologists
for the tumor
and I'll put names to visit a moment on
the tumor comes out if it is at least
fifty percent purity it gets sequenced
both for DNA mainly whole exome also for
RNA seek to get expression analysis and
also to identify fusions so on the RNA
seek that expression analysis goes to
Eric shots proof where a number of
people do a network analysis and make
both Network predictions and even drug
predictions we actually take the whole
exome data so typically we see and i
should say we have we have four patients
in the center right now we just opened
our doors a few weeks ago um we actually
take all the mutations so for example
one patient we're just just going
through this morning has about a hundred
and forty mutations in their tumor we
actually take the what are called the
common variants that drive that are the
base ones like laughs and so on you we
have flies already have that in we take
all the rest of the mutations 135 138
mutations take the fly orthologs we
knock them down in a fly and we ask gene
by gene by Gene functionally speaking do
they make that tumor better worse or no
effect that is we're trying to identify
drivers in a functional way not a
literature way not a model it's the
functional way and so we for example we
just finished doing this as an aversive
driver for a patient that has majorly
thyroid carcinoma we identified eight
different genes that in addition to ret
are driving that tumor and unfortunately
I didn't have that data when I submitted
the slide deck but I could show you
pictures now the difference between that
rough I and when you start putting those
other mutations in to block the eye is
an absolute mess the tumors are enormous
and it really in many cases just simply
kills the fly from aggressive tumors so
we've been treating the red fly now
we're going to start treating this nine
hit fly and so we do drug screens using
our robotics we do strictly fda-approved
drugs you don't even bother with the
single drug screen you do we do to drug
combinations we just assume we're going
to need a cocktail and we look for drug
combinations that work in the fly
if we get that we then test them in mice
if we're able to successfully develop
pdx from the patient's tumor samples we
test it on that in many cases we can't
do that in which case we test in our
model that's as close as possible also
if maybe we test you in pigs for
toxicity they don't have tumors but we
can get a call on hold Pig toxicity
they're closer to us and based on that
we have three different committees that
looks through the scientific data and
also pharmacology committee that looks
at the drug combinations were
recommending we come back to the
oncologist and make a recommendation for
that patient and what's nice is we
actually have a series of drug
combinations which we ranked by various
criteria and so if the patient is it
doesn't work on the first one or it
works for a while but then eventually it
becomes resistant to it we have a set of
other ones that we can also recommend as
well and here is it's actually a large
effort this is just a small sampling of
the people that are involved in this
effort a lot of people have really
pitched in here at Mount Sinai to make
this book you don't know that this will
be successful yet but we expect that
we're going to get better and better at
this as time goes on we'll also get
faster and faster and so I should say
that we're taking medullary thyroid
carcinoma patients colorectal cancer
patients and triple negative breast
cancer patients for a number of reasons
which I can talk about we've chosen
those three so with that to summarize my
talk I told you about our efforts to
build complex drugs through chemistry
plus genetics to build what we call
Polly balanced Polly pharmacology drugs
drugs eight many pathways but in a
rational way the second thing i told you
about is our efforts to build complex
models and i should say with patients
we've developed new technology where we
can very rapidly make a 12 hit fly which
we need for these patients because they
often have up to 12 drivers and finally
i finish by talking about the center for
personalized cancer therapeutics and our
effort to take these basic research
tools and really try to get at the
problems with a patient i should say if
we have one patient that's diabetic we
make the Flies diabetic and then do the
drug screen the patients taking a
particular drug they often are we give
that at low doses to
train the tumor and then do the drug
screen we try to make these as close as
possible to the patient we don't claim
that we understand the mechanistic going
on we just builds accurate models we can
and then we try to cure the fly that I
will stop and this shows that to obtain
continuing education credits please go
to this website and I should also say
that on the at least the left side of my
screen if you have any questions for me
please just type it in the Q&A section
and i'll be happy to address it
otherwise thank you very much other
questions nope okay um how are we doing
okay i think i will end sorry guys i'm
trying to figure out how this works oh
so say question an tastic well whoever
sent to earth and Isaac thank you very
much we're really trying to connect as
much as we can with clinicians for those
of you or clinicians incidentally we're
very open to working with you you're
really trying to understand what are the
issues with these patients meeting these
patients has really taught us a lot
about issues of toxicity and so on and
that's why we've begun to obsess over
these and try to build drugs that are
more accurate I should also say we're
trying to combine this now with immuno
cancer therapy coming in first with
drugs to break the tumor up we're hoping
that it will make them more vulnerable
to immuno some cancer approaches with
nina beaugeois and working with us and
that too will see so are there other
questions okay well I will leave this on
for another minute or two and then I'll
end anything else all right listen thank
you very much everybody for tuning in
and good luck on your work